Don't leave me.
I'm not. I don't know what to do.
Maybe we can cut the cable
With what?
Try the phone again.
Come on.
Fear is a scent
i've seen that thing hailin'
23 years ago
God dammit, slaughterhouse on wheels
when it comes, it will kill anyone that still here
Man speaking : we need a team, shopkeepers, farmers, anyone
anyone who looked this thing eye to eye
and live to tell about it
and wants to do something about it
Man sepaking : what happen here, happened before
Woman speaking : just tell me one thing, did you bring something that can kill it
what is the secret
to what this thing is
it's a secret of hide and killing
Jeepers Creepers
What?
wouldn't the song the guy sing or something?
(Man whistling)